there's a lot of news about possible
talks between ukraine and russia which
can end this war and bring peace back to
all of us your capital minsk is often
mentioned there as the platform for
these talks it's the platform that we
didn't choose and neither did you in
fact it was chosen by russian
authorities
if there wasn't aggressive actions from
your territory we could have talked in
minsk in your capital when you were
neutral we talked in minsk met many
times it's a right and honest way to
talk his neighbors to each other
other cities can be a platform for a
meeting
of course we want peace we want to meet
and put an end to the war warsaw
bratislava budapest istanbul
we offered all of them to the russian
side and we will accept any other city
in a country that hasn't been used for
launching missiles only
last night in ukraine was harsh there
was shelling again and bombardment of
residential areas and civil
infrastructure there is no single object
in the country which occupiers won't
consider as a valid target
they are fighting against everyone and
everything alive against kindergartens
against residential buildings and
ambulances they're using rocket
artillery missiles against entire cities
districts which never had and don't have
now any military infrastructure